[Music]
hello do you hear me well like in the
last rows it's okay because sometimes
there's some problems microphone so
welcome to our presentation we'll talk
about using victory stacks and using
some supervised methods for seeking
similarity between objects for for
objects clustering so this is our agenda
for today so this is our company profile
so we are one of the largest e-commerce
platforms in Central and Eastern Europe
we have million of offers we have
millions of users so a lot of data a lot
of behavioral data coming from our
website so and we use machine learning
and deep learning recently quite a lot
because we have a lot of complicated
data so texts and images for instance so
this is our data science tools that we
use real data scientists at the Allegro
so we use Python a lot so we use
scikit-learn tensorflow and cars for
machining deep learning to transform and
to query our huge data warehouses we use
spark PI spark for instance and presto
which is a very fasting memory query
engine and we use Jupiter notebooks to
share code to experiment with data and
to do some real time to do some
analytics so probably you know a lot of
this stuff so to introduce the topic I
will tell you something about who are
embedding so turning words or our
sentences or phrases into vectors so how
many how many of you used swore to back
our glove so quite a lot of people so I
don't have to talk
about this for people who didn't use it
when you have a word or a sentence you
really don't want to 1 how to encode it
into just very long vectors of zeros and
ones because then it's very difficult to
work with such data especially if you
have a very large corpus like millions
or ten thousands of millions of words
it's much better to use some clever
techniques like so a very famous one was
created at Google by McAuliffe and his
team which is called war Tyvek it's
reusing neural network to turn words
sequences of words into vectors so there
are many flavors to this technique like
continues backwards which you predict a
word given its context or skip Graham
when you really predict the context
given a word but the result of such
technique is usually a vector so it's
like position of this word in a highly
multi-dimensional space and many nice
things you can do so for instance
machines prefer vectors that really
symbolic representation so you can feed
this vectors to other techniques like
machine learning you can do analogy
tests I will show you it on the next
slide and which is very useful and we
use it a lot so you can really turn
whole sentences into vectors so for
instance if you have this very smart
algorithm that changes a word into
vector usually we don't use such long
short vectors here so these vectors
usually are like 256 over hundred 28
units long but this is just for the
presentation so you can change each word
in the vector and then really average
this vectors along the axis so along the
dimensions and you can have a sentence
vector it's very nice but we didn't use
word to Veck it's very nice but
sometimes it takes too long to Train so
what we use is a glove algorithm have
you heard about this
so it was developed at Stanford
University and the difference between
word Tyvek and glove is that in glove
the first step is calculating the
calculus matrix and then what you really
do is you run the model on this
co-occurrence matrix it's much better
for large corpuses because for instance
you have big data reoccuring in your
sentences many times and before to work
you have to train the model every time
it finds big data and with glove model
is just it's trained only once on such a
pair and it works very well with this
famous analogy task so for instance if
you have a vector for King and then you
subtract man from this vector and add
women then you receive something similar
to Queen so we can have this very nice
language relationships encoded into
these vectors but the problems of we try
to run some very simple models for
similarity on these vectors but and we
tried to use some unsupervised
techniques for customization of these
vectors but it didn't work very well so
we were searching for some architecture
or some machine learning tool that will
allow us to train something supervised
techniques which are usually much
stronger and much better for such data
using these vectors are using word
embedding and we found an interesting
idea which is called this CMS recurrent
neural networks or CMI's neural networks
depends on the architecture when the
thing you are trying to build is so it's
like a supervised way to to learn a
model that some objects are similar that
are just the same or and some objects
are should be very distance yeah so this
is the supervised method for learning
for learning similarity between pairs
you can use text so you can turn texts
into vector
and feed it into model or you can use
images for instance you can run some
image net networks on on your images
turn them into vectors or like for Gigi
and then six similarity between objects
so it seems like appropriate method for
our tasks so the problem in Allegro is
sometimes that we have many offers and
we don't know that they are the same so
for instance in books we have many
offers of books like a lot of drinks in
many different versions so far as the
title might be tolki and Lord of the
Rings or a lot of drinks by Tolkien or
Lord of the Rings very cheap sending 24
hours from or so and certainly that and
we want to cluster them together so that
the similarity between such objects
should be very high and there were some
successful applications such such
methods you can find articles like the
one by text Cardinal team I think they
are now the part of the Salesforce
company so they trained the CMI's neural
networks on different names for the same
job offers so for instance architect and
senior Java specialist were the same and
they wanted to train some models too
clustered such such job offers together
and there are some nice nice modules
based on tensorflow
published by eBay so they have probably
similar business challenges like we like
we have you can find them on github and
we already have experimented with glove
before before using this CME's neural
networks so for instance we used them to
find brands in offer titles and we had
great results so how many of you have
seen this Yummy's neural network
architecture
not many people ok so you just take
two objects like you can and you can
embed your text if you use text with
some methods like love or war Tyvek or
star space new method or you can just
watch one on what encode them into inter
vectors and use some recurrent neural
network layers like like this
bi-directional layer to encode to encode
these factors so you train this vectors
with the whole network done and then you
can really use this vectors and some
hidden layers in your network to
calculate this causing distance or or
you can Euclidean distance okay so it
looks like this you do have two
sentences for instance or two images or
two offers then you have this neural
network architecture you might have many
hidden layers here it depends on your
task you have outputs from this networks
and then you have discussing similarity
as an output and then it should be like
here in between minus 1 and 1 so one is
for similar objects and so we call them
positive examples and minus one is a
negative object so we call them negative
examples and we calculate the loss
function by using this output and the
target variable and then we just back
prop the error on to until your hidden
layers and our end ends if you use them
[Music]
so what we had to do is to prepare the
data set so we had a nice set of
clusters so this were the titles and
authors from website called the be me to
touch they were already web script I
think before we use them so this were
the positive parts for our model and we
took create the data set we queried our
search engine at le gros for for the
books so then you had a pair you had a
title of the offer from Allegro and then
you had this cluster so this was this
outer entitled from from this web page
will be much attache this gave us around
70,000 examples to Train on our network
on but this was a small data set for
Allegra
so just very small categories so then we
use database from Polish National
Library which offers like almost all
books that were published in Polish you
have outer ESPN and title and many other
things about the book and then we also
use the search engine not Ali grow to
create the data set and then we had a
three million data set so much bigger
and there was a first integration where
we so we found that many sects
monetarily grew really place ESPN
numbers of the identification number for
the book not in the title but in the
description of the offer it's not a
required parameter but it's quite often
used so then we could join the the
national library database with with our
offers using this parameter so it gave
us smaller data set but we've moved with
much higher quality so you might find
these results of it straight so this was
the first iteration just on the science
fiction books so there's a habit there's
a difference between training and the
test moment so in the training moment
and that the accuracy you receive is the
accuracy of placing the negative and
positive person so labeling them in a
correct way but in the test moment we
didn't really wanted to the model to
check whether this pair is a positive
power a negative power it's not it's not
the final solution we were seeking for
so what so the test moment is you take
offer from the test data set not used in
learning and give all possible clusters
to the model and then find the cluster
which has the smallest distance between
this offer and the cluster so it's like
okay here you have a offer from where I
grow and find the best cluster so this
despair of outer entitle from from other
database so this would be the final
cluster for this offer so we had a quite
nice results for such data it's not a
simple data its text with a lot of stop
words and different phrases not very
clean so we had some problems with the
model fitted on the very large database
of free million offers and we really
overcome this obstacle in the first
iteration we changed the model a bit so
we improved the last
we used imbalance learning so we gave
the model much more and negative
examples in the training moment done
previously and what we did is just
yesterday we use both character encoding
as an input and the glove vector of the
whole sentence as input in just one
model so it has just two inputs and it
learned that much better
I think so there were some experiments
we did on the data so Rafa will present
them so we organized our work in the way
that mmm McCoy was working on a pro on
one one model with different approaches
and I was working on another one
my was more like research one because I
only worked on the smaller the smallest
dataset so regarding the date I use only
these fantasy books regarding with the
wort embeddings I used cloth with some
default for just for a start settings
like window 5 dimensions 50 and my model
was Imus neural network with distance
with own distance and the last function
was contrastive loss and this is the
implementation of that comes from this
this article so there's quite a lot of
options that you can choose with when
you when you want to model something
let's say hyper parameters and as you
can see there's just some small list of
different different things like data the
way you prepare the data the way you
represent the data just the words and
when you move from words to to the
sentences
and when you decide that your
representation would be glove there are
also have some hyper parameters another
thing is about the training set it can
be balanced or imbalanced and the next
next thing is just the mode of the
architecture that and all the parts of
the the architectures or the hyper
parameters so these are the hyper hyper
parameters that I decided to work with
and the orange ones are the ones that I
do some experiments with just shortly
briefly about the the last function the
contrast it flows it it works there's
different laws for different different
parts this example for the distance
similarity because I think it's easier
to explain it on this example so the
thing is that when you have a negative
power and it already has really the part
in the data has a really nice similarity
he wants to penalize it harder than when
you even when you have a positive power
but with just but similarity so you just
set the margin and when the similarity
is over bigger than this in this margin
that you can probably find out using
some descriptive analysis just for the
stars at least when you provide the
model with the higher cost function okay
so the first first results accuracy on
training set and test set was was really
really high but as mentioned by by McCoy
this was just the balanced data set and
the the thing that should work in our in
our environment is the one that with
which Peaks from all the clusters to
under that
best and when you when you test the data
and such data set so you just pick one
title and compare the results
mm to every cluster it was just 44
percent so the idea was okay maybe we do
not have enough negative pairs within
our training set and it does not cover
the the the drivel data or the usage
that we would like to have that's why we
decided to test different imbalance
ratios and as you can see the model is
quite stable because the accuracy even
on test set is not dropping a lot
however the accuracy and test set coming
from this Cartesian product is
increasing a lot so even when you have
imbalance ratio forty to one so there is
40 40 times more negative pers it's cool
it's still quite stable the accuracy
accuracy and this let's say final test
data is really high but it's not much
better it's a little bit worse than the
one with imbalance 21 so I decided to
stop with with testing this this
approach so another thing that came to
mind was regarding the the gloves so
these two hyper parameters window size
and number of dimensions and we came up
with two hypotheses the one says that
the smaller the window the better
representation the second one more
dimensions better representation so the
second one seems to be quite obvious
because you will have more detailed
representation the first one may not be
so here is a little bit of an intuition
and this Oh W means other world TW means
title world and
aw means outer world so if you take for
example a window of four words and I
just pick the window from the left side
and in graph you always have the similar
window
symmetric window you will describe you
will keep quite for a long time this
other word that for you should be
treated as stop words it's like rubbish
when you compare it to the to the to the
cluster so you move this this window to
describe another world but you keep
quiet for a long time this this other
words so we thought maybe it will not
this is the problem but when you for
example use just one word as a window so
the window size is one just in the next
step you already go out from this let
say stop words and here's the the grid
search for this these parameters and it
seems like the first hypothesis is more
or less confirmed and the second one
surprisingly not or maybe not
surprisingly the the the corpus was not
big enough and it might be it might have
been a problem so we just used the
representations and we found we
introduced them as a very simple very
naive predictive model just by taking
the the distance calculating the
distance to each of two every our
cluster we decided that the one with the
lowest distance is the best according
just to this glove representation so the
next thing was to take the the best
glove and once more around it on
different data coming from different
balance ratios and compare it with the
previous results unfortunately very very
not better so
you cannot it's difficult to say which
represent which Bluff representation
will be the best for our final model and
it's it's difficult to find this
representation that will improve your
final model and the thing that we we
already thought that maybe also the case
that might be important here just to
improve this imbalancing we could think
only about negative parts with the
highest similarity so that you make the
model the task for the model really
difficult so for example the difference
between positive and negative power will
be just 1% or something like that so
that you will not have to do so huge you
will not have to work with so huge
imbalance ratios but still you will make
the model work better because it's
comparing for example to the normal
cluster algorithms we do not work with
we do not control how much we move our
classrooms from each other so that's
that's really a problem here and
regarding the next steps McCoy will tell
you what are our thoughts ok so what we
did in our models we used character
level encoding and sentence vectors but
as well we can use models which you fit
on the whole sequences of glove
represent glove vectors for each word so
these models might have much more data
and the third data would be much more
rich so you don't lose a lot of
information when you compress
vectors descender this words into one
sentence Victor what I did yesterday and
it works quite fine so you provide two
types of input into your model so first
you use this character encoding
character level encoding and then you
also use a glove vector so like two
different representations for the same
sentence over the same title and the
model works a bit better yeah so and
also what you can use for such models
you can do you can switch off this shirt
layers so you calculate separate weights
for titles and for clusters
it might work better but we have to test
it
I also there's a different architecture
which is much more similar to neural
machine translation so encoding decoding
networks with recurrent layers inside
and then from the methodological point
of view would be a much better for us so
we what we do now we try to make some
clusters and titles more similar so with
less distance in this multi-dimensional
space and some words and some clusters
we move them apart but then in such
models if we use translation models then
the cluster would be just an output for
the model so we shouldn't really move
the cluster in this multi-dimensional
space we should be constant and then we
should read make a model that will
translate our inputs our title into this
cluster but this is our hypothesis we
will likely test it in the future and
the last thing just to make this speech
a more funny one
we found one word embedding joke
available online so this is it maybe not
the best one but first
laughing yeah so if you're in the war
two vet models and causing distances you
find it quite funny so this is the last
page for you mostly saw some links some
nice articles and some nice books about
deep learning about CME's architecture
and about word embedding so thank you
very much and you've got some questions
so when i'm my question is basically
about this exotic embedding of window
one so the question would be because the
intuition behind it is I have my latent
space which I initialize somehow and
then based on the co-occurrence matrix
I'm just moving the vectors the ones
that are co-occurring that I'm gonna
move them closer the ones that are not
I'm gonna just put them apart right
that's how I get my embedding and then
of course I put it at the bottom of my
of my net I'm training some some things
on top of it my question is was that
layer frozen in which case I think
that's very weird if it wasn't because I
don't think this embedding space based
on one of a window length one is is very
dense then so it's it's I've never seen
it before it's very interesting that it
that it works but my question is whether
you check the frozen and unfrozen
scenario for this for for this embedding
layer and and how dense was this
embedding space because um I kind of
don't see how it learned an embedding
representation and it's very interesting
you know how how that happened with
window one
maybe it was not really visible on this
short presentation but window one you
just take one word yes around your
target words not zero was so so then it
works yeah zero words would be just
random nice yeah just randomization yeah
so yeah so maybe rough I want it show
this is the target word we just take one
words both direction okay sorry so I if
you want to ask some more questions just
we can talk later
you